the great gatsby leonardo dicaprio has
the great gatsby he is [ __ ] awesome
by far the best thing in this movie he's
joining ryan wright's club of guys whose
dick he would suck toby maguire is in it
he's okay but him and leonardo dicaprio
play off each other very well there is a
little bit of a homo erotic relationship
between him and leonardo dicaprio but i
would not suck tubby mcguire's dick
carrie mulligan's in this film she's
beautiful to look at every guy seems to
want her even her cousin played by tubby
mcguire another reason why i wouldn't
suck his dick joel edgerton does a
really good job playing tom the villain
in the movie if you're wondering who
joel edgerton is i don't [ __ ] know
who he is either yes the visual effects
are good but they can be very
distracting the production design is
spectacular there is some wonderful
cinematography but i gotta say the
directing and writing kind of did suck
balls this movie has no emotional core
throughout most of it you're like i
don't give a [ __ ] about most of these
[ __ ] people a lot of it just seems to
rush rush rush rush and be way more
about style over substance the movie was
way too long didn't know exactly what
the film wanted to be about bazlerman
what were you thinking but although this
film didn't really have a strong
emotional impact through most of it
there are some scenes in the film that
are truly great so overall i wouldn't
call it the great gatsby more like the
okay gatsby
oh
god i bet no one has said that yet
oh
oh original comedy is my thing let me
get straight to the point here all in
all i gotta say i like just enough
things to say this film got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
the show why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box and tell me what you
thought about the great gatsby whether
it sucked whether it was good
just shake the movie on its own merits
try not to compare it to the book and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and subscribe to my channel
on the link right there
you